So we learned the autoenccoders and we
discussed how they can handle sequences.
For example, a sentence like hello world
can be encoded to a fixed size latent
and then decoded to the translated let's
say in French. So like we discussed this
is a maybe a preliminary solution
because it's not really the most
efficient especially if we go to longer
sentences or large text.
So if we have varying lengths of u
sequences we are encoding all of them to
a fixed size latent.
For example, if we have a fiveword
tweet, we encode to the same Z as in a
500word essay or a entire book. They all
have the same Z. Which means that if the
length of the sequence is getting
larger, the amount of information that Z
can share with each one of the tokens
uh will be reduced. And at some point if
the length of the sequence goes to a
let's say very large value the
information that Z can capture from each
one of these tokens gets goes to zero.
Second problem is the autoenccoders
treat inputs as of as a bag of features.
They don't really naturally preserve the
order. For example, consider these two
inputs and the encoder basically treat
them similarly. There's no explicit
positional encoding meaning that the
order is not preserved but the order we
know matter at least in language these
two sentences are not the same. The
third problem is we resolve the variable
length uh issue with padding which then
wastes a lot of computation and then
model learns patterns about where the
real data ends are not real and it's
sparious. Moreover, we are really not
capitalizing on batch efficiency because
we are giving one sequence at a time and
within the sequence we may have outliers
that can destroy really the benefits of
the averaging. We had another option
which was truncating the sequence to a
fixed length. But here again we will
have some issues with the information uh
that will be lost. And then also if some
sequences are just naturally long uh we
are not able to learn for them because
the autoenccoder basically feed
everything at once. One last issue is uh
there is no natural chunking meaning
that if the data comes in a se in a
streaming sense uh we should wait until
the entire sequence ends and then feed
it to the auto autoenccoder. This is
really undesirable because sometimes we
want for example live translation and we
want something that can handle it and
give us the output so far for example
until we have the sequence then when
there is an addition to the sequence the
the output can be uh updated. So here we
introduce the RNN the recurrent neural
network architectures that deals with
all of these issues that we discussed.
Let's start the design with this goal
that we want to maintain an
understanding of the sequence over time.
Let's try to do it using a a naive
approach where we are still using the
the feed forward neural network. So we
we give the first part or first chunk or
first element of the sequence that is
coming like this. Maybe this index can
be time and then we feed this to each
one of these element to fit forward nor
our network and that gives us an a
context or a latent of a length Z. So
basically this means that uh there is a
narrowing down of the size here. Okay.
So we can do the same here and maybe we
are using the a different encoder. So
let's just for the sake of simplicity
let's call this F1. This is f_sub_2.
This gives us h2. And then uh we want to
build a way to for these hes to carry
over and we want to use that
information. So let's just fit this to
the next uh function. So here uh that
means that there will be an input to
f_sub_2. So these two are both inputs to
f_sub_2 meaning that we are
concatenating them. So that means that
we uh we start from scratch here. This
can be a bunch of zeros or null. Right?
So this way we accumulate the context or
information over time. We call this hes
like a state that basically tells us if
you have age and the input you have
everything to approximate the next age.
So we can write this down like this.
Okay. So so far so good. Um what is the
difficulty with this is ft is a time
variant function and it's not easy to
learn. Besides with the length of this
sequence there will be more and more
parameters with the additional fs. So
there will be a parameter explosion and
we are not dealing with a so in time
series analysis we call it a
non-stationerity which things are
changing each time and that's not really
what we want. we want uh to learn
something that is valid in the entire
time series. So let's simplify this and
make ft constant. So now we have an f
that once given ht minus one and an xt
it will give us the next h. So that
means that all of these fs are the same
and besides we can do it. This is a
neural network and a neural network can
be rich enough that can learn the shared
relationship here. So in dynamical
system this uh structure is very common
and if you notice this preserve this uh
property that we have everything we need
at this stage at this step right to
predict H2. This is known as a marovian
property. You can also think of age here
as a memory, maybe a short-term memory,
but it's enough memory to give us a good
prediction for age or for the next
updated memory that we are going to
carry over for the next step. Again, we
resolve all of those issues that we had
in the uh autoenccoder. There is no
one-time compression for Z. It's instead
information accumulates here. Also, we
have a natural ordering, right? There's
no issues with temporal structures. We
are able to handle any size, length of
sequences as we are feeding it this way.
We can also deal with streaming uh data
because this is naturally handled here.
The computation efficiency is also
better as we only use memory uh as we
want. There's no padding or sparious end
of sequence learning and give us the
updated memory for the next prediction.
We can use this h and do the decoding to
anything we want. For example, at each
time point we can get an output or maybe
we should we can wait until the end get
an output. So that is depending on the
design.
Are we done here? Well, it's important
to look at how this architecture can be
trained. So when we do a forward pass
like this until we get to the point that
we are computing the loss and we want to
back propagate this loss. The back
propagation requires a product that is a
function of parameters of whh
and the activation which here is an
activation that is between minus1 and
one uh which is tang t t t t t t t t t t
t t t t t t t t t t t t t t t t t t t t
t t t t t t t t t tangent hyperbolic. So
there will be a multiplication by a term
here that is less than or equal than one
or identity. Okay, this means that
because we have a product there is an
exponential either growth or decay or in
other word we have either an explosion
or a vanishing gradient. So in the book
you can look at the derivations but the
main point here is we have to deal with
one of these two cases all the time and
it's not easy to handle. For example,
you may think of gradient clipping uh as
a band-aid, but that's not really the
the solution because basically you're
reducing the convergence of the gradient
descent significantly um by basically
reducing the effect of large mistaken
gradient steps. So this is known as back
propagation through time. And the the
biggest problem is when we are doing
this back propagation for the entire
sequence. But maybe we can reduce this
problem because now that we have this
nice architecture, maybe we can just
chop the sequence into smaller part
because after all foss
right this is this marovian uh property
that we can capitalize on. So what I
mean is maybe we can just chop the the
sequence into smaller part and give each
one of these smaller part to the RNN to
train on. So basically we can have a lot
of these small sequences and do batch
training because after all f should be
able to deal with all of these sequences
or subsequences.
Of course how to choose these
subsequences is important. Maybe we can
just random uh choose random lengths
subsequences in our batch and then in
expectation basically we will get a
unbiased f but in practice really it's
not necessary to do with this random
size segments and you can just pick uh
segment size. So in that case we know
that after a few steps maybe here for
text 20 to 50 the influence of the past
observation gets smaller and smaller on
the current gradient. I mean after all
the ingredient will will decay. So it's
not really as important to have that
long sequences and as we said the
information also gets diluted as it pass
through many of these nonlinearities
that we have inside those steps. If you
remember we had this tangent hyperbolic
and then this variable length sequences
also induce some variance into our
gradient. So for example if each one of
these many many batches has very
different truncation lengths this brings
some noise that uh somehow reduce the
benefits that we get from this
occasional longer uh segments in the
randomized version. Also the
optimization gets more difficult. Also
when you have a disregular segment size
uh it's like we are we have simpler
model and that means simpler inductive
bias training will be more stable and
this uh regular truncation is like
really like a mild regular razor and we
are not overfeeding to long range
correlation. So we learn a very good
short per memory for our RNN that is
remaining robust for out of distribution
data. Okay. So before going on and code
the RNN just a few practical
recommendation after this discussion. So
we can come up with a fixed chunk size
maybe in the character level models 35
has been a norm. We have to initialize
the state and here we can initialize
with zero to learn the initial state.
We still need to do gradient clipping
because the vanishing gradient and the
exploding gradient is still an issue
here. We haven't yet completely dealt
with it. And then for longer sequences
we have to we have to deal with uh
bigger problems. So it's not really this
vanilla RNN is not the real solution. So
let's just go with what we have and then
later we will come up with better
solution for longer sequences.